andrew let me ask you uh did you uh  i don't know if you this is public  information or not did you vote for joe  biden is that who you voted for uh yeah  okay so how do you think he's doing  i think that it is not a great time in  america right now and i i hear from  folks who are close to joe um and  there's a sense that you know his  energies are not what they uh they they  could be um that his team sometimes  doesn't trust him to freelance  uh and so when he goes into a meeting  like there are you know not  traditional negotiations  in the way that you would want them to  be uh so i you know that if you look at  it from the outside you're like hey like  you know i'm not sure  um if he has the energy and the  wherewithal and i think those concerns  are very real if you enjoyed this short  clip click over here to watch another  short clip and if you want to watch the  entire episode the entire podcast click  here  [Music]  you